The Korean Peninsula is no longer under the direct influence of Typhoon Chaba,...
...but the southern parts of Korea that were battered by the storm...
...are still grappling with rescue and recovery operations.
And more reports on the extent of the damage are still coming in.
Three casualties were reported in Busan,...
...among them is a construction worker who was killed after a crane toppled over,...
...and an elderly woman who died after falling from the roof of her house.
Three casualties were reported in the nearby city of Ulsan,...
...which was also slammed with torrential rain and powerful winds.
The General Insurance Association of Korea reported Wednesday...
...the typhoon caused more than nine million US dollars in damages.
More than 500 homes have been flooded, and more than 1,600 vehicles submerged.
Around 230,000 homes suffered power outages...
...and dozens of cultural properties were damaged.
Almost 200 people from 90 households were forced to evacuate,...
...and they are currently staying at local schools and community centers.